[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible ça pas de vous vous
êtes rapprocher de capucines ou écouter
le maple de buteur faites vous un petit
bisou à vélo
[Applaudissements]
et
à ton âge ta pas contre l'histoire un
sursis et new york non voilà la capitale
des états unis boston chicago
non non c'est pas choisi alors c'est
quoi non c'est vrai je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure
washington dc ça souffle vous avez dit
washington mais vous êtes japan acloque
vous avez notre notre canal + qui m'a
dit voilà qui m'attend la proposition
est alors de câlins et alors alors j'ai
refusé mais c'est pas bluff ou pas non
retenu pour les bleus ouais ouais mais
n'a jamais juste envie d donc d'essayer
d'embrasser une fille